frank miller wrote the dark knight
returns
batman year one daredevil born again
and sin city classics of the genre
he also created all-star batman and
robin
the dark knight strikes again and holy
terror
which were absolutely terrible if you've
been following my read-through and
review of the dark knight series
then you know that the only thing
consistent about the comic creator
is his inconsistency back with a book
that no one asked for
the dark knight 3 the master race the
writer has the opportunity to either
save the franchise or ruin it
even further beginning in 2015
the book has suffered from delay after
delay but with the help of brian
azzarello
and annie cuba dc have guided miller to
the point that is now released
as a trade analyzing the book page by
page
i will be discussing whether it's worth
your time or if this series should
finally
have a good death that's like that's
like
never mind so let's dive right into
batman the dark knight
the master race the book opens in the
batcave
we hover over the destruction left in
the wake of the dark knight strikes
again
and are told there's no such thing as a
good death
yeah that isn't frank because people
just can't let things die
and they have to keep bringing them back
and making them worse
nice one anyway this would have been a
brilliant opening
had it not been ruined by the text
message captions that plagued the first
issue
it seems that the people of gotham
haven't discovered predictive texts yet
and are still typing in that annoying
way that everyone did in the early 2000s
now i would never slag off my childhood
but bar tattoo and endless days of
masturbation
there's very little i remember from
those days
later throughout the opening bubbles are
things like
i seen him and bs
nobody can beat the bat for three years
it's hard to read anything that's
written so badly
it's like reading a melania trump speech
that hasn't been written by someone else
i took a slight dislike to the opening
chapter because of it
whilst i understand this homage as the
original dark knight returns
even back then it was dated when
creating a sequel you should carry some
things over that work
and leave the relics in the past even
with an update this makes the initial
issues difficult to get into
and i'm glad that someone in power
intervened at some point and made miller
and
azarello dial it back in the following
chapters
because it reads worse than stephen
hawkins when his windows
is going through an update whilst
perhaps being overly critical of the
text i'm happy to say that the art is
the best that it's ever been
in the entire dark knight series whilst
it has about as much competition as a
mugabe election
cubert still stands head and shoulders
above the rest his work
always flashing elements of miller now
stands directly
above it he was the perfect choice for
this book and carries over a lot of the
aesthetics that made the designs in the
originals pop
where they're handling large cityscapes
or simple surroundings such as corridors
and streets
cuba captures them all perfectly still
steeped in politics
miller and azarello this time capture a
lot of media coverage in a satirical
sense
perfectly news anchors blurt out
comments unchecked and it's clear the
creators have been looking for more
faults in fox news than alex jones
referencing this wonder woman comments
on how the world regarded her kind as
saviors until they had potential to
become threats
it really speaks volumes to how humanity
in general
deifies public figures then crucifies
them
then resurrects them this isn't just an
allegory for christ
it's something i've noticed that happens
to people in the spotlight
how many celebrities have been put on a
pedestal stripped of it and then
repositioned back there by a new
generation
countless throughout the first issue we
see the police chase down the new bat
figure
getting the reveal that it is in fact
carrie kelly in the cape and cowl
she announces that bruce is dead leaving
a brilliant twist ending for the first
issue
but also signifying the rebirth that the
caped crusader would go through
this is the overarching theme of the
dark knight saga and it clearly ties
into a christ metaphor
as well as a comment on society the bat
died
was resurrected bruce died was
resurrected
superman died he returned and this motif
appears repeatedly through the books to
its ending
miller has created a universe that kills
its heroes more often than not
but they return whenever needed one of
the most unique aspects of this book is
the inclusion of the mini issue
in the graphic novel print they are full
size and honestly work better in this
format as opposed to the original
acting as supplementary material they
focus on the universe's side characters
missing from most is batman so they can
either be skipped by the casual reader
or
analyzed by the hardcore fan adding more
of a backstory than specific plot
elements
they really enrich the overall story
when taking on this book i expected to
be able to breeze through it
on my second read through though i've
come to realize that it's actually
jam-packed with content
cuba has done a brilliant job of
capturing miller's style and borrow a
few hang-ups from the series legacy
the initial chapter does a brilliant job
of rekindling us
within the world of the dark knight
returns once more
the second chapter of the dark knight 3
centers around the imprisonment of
carrie kelly
and her eventual escape during
interrogation
at the hands of commissioner yindal we
learn about bruce wayne's demise after
the beating he received from lex luthor
in the dark knight strikes again on
first three this interrogation is an
enthralling moment
however it loses all sentimentality upon
the appearance of a living and breathing
bruce
later in the issue having never actually
been dead
the lie told by kerry was only
implemented
as a distraction respectively it strips
away
a lot of the legitimacy that this issue
has and had it not been for the subplot
the majority of book two would have been
simply
filler mirroring kerry's imprisonment
and release we see the atom free the
citizens of the bottle city of kandor
upon liberation the religious zealots
led by quor
murder the atom and initiate their plan
to rule the world
the bottled city of pandora was made up
of shrunken kryptonians
stripped of their power they must have
felt persecuted for years
and now upon their release they seek
revenge metaphorically this works as a
synonym
of the middle east terrorized by the
west for decades they have
as of late fought back and suffered at
the hands of our counter attack they are
villains in the same way that the
kryptonians are
and act as the perfect modern day paul
working as both a comic book enemy
whilst
also providing satire to the wars we
fight today
they feel like a formidable antagonist
it's difficult to draw from this which
side miller is on
it would be wrong to label him as a
racist as one could argue that he
provides pros
and cons to both aspects i.e batman
parades around carelessly destroying
property
enforcing his rule over the world and
disobeying the law
he is labelled as a hero however when
the freed kandorians do it
it is seen as vilnius similarly america
and the uk candidly invaded the middle
east but presented it as liberation
we were labeled as the good guys because
of media coverage
and fear perhaps this is miller's view
of the contradictory nature of
outlets like fox news who praise our
attacks on iraq and iran
they are famous for demonizing them yet
many could argue that they merely
counter attacked
using the same means that we did to
provoke them
whether intentional or not it certainly
adds an interesting subtext to the plot
and it's great to see miller provide
balance to both sides of the argument
instead of clearly choosing one as he
has been guilty of
in the past one of the hilarious aspects
about the candorian attack
is that throughout we see humans not
even looking up from their phone to
witness the devastation
around them it adds volume to the work
and cements the need for batman
as a race we have become apathetic to
most things due to our constant fixation
on our technology please don't leave
this review though and turn off your
phone
news anchors comment on the destruction
but they merely report
people pass the decay but don't get
involved we are truly lost and miller
wants to enforce that without action
nothing can ever be accomplished
it's only upon the destruction of the
mobile satellites that people finally
look up and take action
we are slaves zombies that require a
constant hit of dopamine to feel
happiness
it's clear the creative team wants us to
come off our phones and take notice of
the world around us
i absolutely loved this aesthetic and
paradoxically it shows miller still has
a keen eye for the media
and mentality of the people that he
bases his books
on holding the world to ransom the
candorians demand that earth surrender
and become their slaves
in a triumphant moment that rivals the
batman v superman fight in the dark
knight strikes again
bruce returns in the cape and cowl and
tells them to go to hell
it really packs a punch and lets you
know there's some life in the old guy
yet
superman returns and we really feel like
we have our a team back
as we join them as they head into battle
issues two and three certainly pick up
the pace
after a slow start from the former
introducing the books villains they
perfectly demonstrate the mind state
that many people have towards certain
sects of society
these chapters definitely get better the
more times they are read
and as a collection act brilliantly at
setting up the showdown between the
world's finest
and the candorians
we join lara the daughter of superman
and wonder woman as she sides with the
candorians in an affront to her father
refusing to fight back superman takes a
beating finding superman guilty of lying
to the people of earth
due to the fact that he presented
himself as the last kryptonian
when kandor exists they cover him in
dark matter
and burn him in a collective laser eye
blast after this the candorians deliver
earth with an
ultimatum give us batman or we will
destroy the planet
the people of earth afraid of the
alternative outcome
demand batman surrender like an animal
caught in a trap they self-mutilate
right envelope gotham fear driving them
to destroy everything in sight to draw
the dark knight out
they are truly lost throughout the
narrative it is highlighted that
superman is one of the people
the candorians despise this fact and
view as a weakness
perhaps it is superman was always more
clark than the man of steel
and for better or for worse he was one
of us weak and
pacifist he is a shell of the man he
used to be he symbolizes the apathy of
the people
batman however demonstrates that they
need powerful symbols to shake them out
of it
and i believe that superman's returned
to the battle upon the re-emergence of
the caped crusader
signifies the shift in the people's
attitude to taking things lying down
riding back into town the dark knight
returns playing heavily upon nostalgia
he is equipped with the batmobile and
armor suit from the prior entries
ready to tackle the problem head-on he
rides for war it's brilliant to see
bruce back in the saddle in what is
arguably one of the most iconic suits
that he has ever worn
it's a truly triumphant moment that
elevates the book and definitely stands
strong
as one of its high points lacing the
clouds with kryptonite reign
batman cunningly disarms the candorians
of their powers and with health from
clark
he wails on them unfortunately it's
during this period in the book that the
mini comics fall to their lowest point
we get an
absolutely dismal carrie kelly story and
the lara one that has a worse love scene
than the dark knight strikes again
we see bal and lara romantically flying
through the sky whilst lovemaking
and the flashes of the wonder woman
superman scene are enough to induce
noise here
is it a bird is it a plane no
it's the worst part of the entire book
poor and art and pacing they really feel
like phonemes
at this point the gimmick had to be
sustained no matter
what and due to this the inclusions feel
forced
i would much rather have focused on the
main battle instead of having to divert
from it with these side stories
and the book becomes a better read if
these are skipped clashing between a
stellar main plot and a far
inferior sub one the middle section of
the book seems to really struggle with
delivering on its potential
there's a lot of great work here but
it's juxtaposed completely by the
substandard side stories that feel like
pointless diversions
it's brilliant seeing superman and
batman fighting side by side once more
feeling like the arc and animosity
between the two has come full circle
the world's finest stand out on every
page that they grace
the candorians don't take it lying down
and watching the battle between human
and superhuman is a thrilling one that
packs the book's first real punch
staying true to its roots by remaining
comicy there's a feeling of joy on every
panel throughout the battle
seeing carrie almost kill bal with a
kryptonite rock in a slingshot
could be viewed as slightly twee but it
works to great effect and feels true to
the character's origins
the narrative doesn't end with this
battle though and the candorians that
flee cement themselves as poor losers by
shooting batman in the back with a heat
vision laser
this sends him into a flat line standing
firm is a brilliant battle the
midsection fight certainly delivers upon
all of the setup
thus far whilst relying heavily on fan
service it still delivers on some unique
moments that add
true characteristic to this book it's
gut wrenching to see batman take a fall
at issue 6's climax
and this speaks volumes as to just how
invested i was in the characters at this
point
it was the first time since reading the
original dark knight returns book that i
felt dc were back on track with their
frank miller universe
and this is one of the highs of the saga
it's also in the section that the mini
issues begin to pick up
we see lara battle wonder woman and the
book is laced with regret on the
latter's part that really adds weight to
the fight
realizing that laura was raised wrong
it's up to wonder woman to put her in
line
relatable on a parent verse trial level
i'm sure every reader can think back to
a point in their life
when they waged war against their mother
or father and were put back in their
place
it adds a subtext that was missing from
the earlier mini comics
and feels like a huge upswing in
comparison in the aftermath of the fight
we see some hilarious news coverage on
the event
donald trump states that we won just
like i said we would
and now we'll make the kryptonians pay
to rebuild gotham city
you're gonna love it and the book feels
like a sophisticated look at modern day
media
images are splashed across iphone
screens and it adds weight to the fact
that nowadays for better or worse
everything is filmed once again this
hammer is home the point that everyone
is now connected
and we can either work as a cohesive
unit or choose not to
either way it paints the picture that we
as a race have the opportunity to strive
or fall by the wayside it was during
this point that i was stuck with the
realization that perhaps the master race
pronoun used in the title
isn't referring to the candorians it's
us
filled with racial connotations it
pinpoints a human outlook on other
civilizations
we often view ourselves as above others
and lash out with violence at signs of
weakness
we take what we can in order to further
our own means and this causes us to
neglect the good of others for our own
goals
this motif is laced throughout the book
and reassured me that miller and
azarella were putting depth into the
work that would be missed by many
readers
seeming like a mere action comic this
subtext behind the story has a wealth of
work
to look into and analyze i urge readers
to reread the work
to see what they missed the first time
one of the most controversial aspects of
the book is the rejuvenization of bruce
wayne
placing the lazarus pit upon his demise
the hero returns reborn
a young man once more whilst many scoff
at the idea of bruce ever using the pit
i see it as a get out of jail free card
that allows batman to exist in every era
in real life the cape crusader probably
would seek out the fountain of youth in
order to continue his war on crime
and similar to rey she requires it in
order to complete his never-ending
mission
dissimilar to reish bruce is a good man
at heart and he would only use it to
have a positive aspect instead of
blaming it for driving him
insane even if he scoffs at clark for
reviving him with it it still gives him
an
opportunity to carry forth the wisdom he
gained with old age
and place it in the body of a young man
the dark knight has truly returned
this section of the book really improved
the quality of the story and that part
it felt as good as the original source
material
i was left open mouthed several times
and it delivered on the punches both
physically
and metaphorically launching an attack
on the amazonians
the latter part of the book feels like a
beautiful depiction of war
it's thrilling to see wonder woman rise
to the forefront of this saga after
being solidly planted in the background
the face-off is glorious and it's a
triumphant moment that works as a
standalone issue
and as part of the collection following
this is the spectacular mini issue
which centers around commissioner yindal
taking down bruno
and the rest of the remaining joker gang
it's very
very god damn frank miller but there's a
lot to like here
playing heavily on nostalgia it's a nice
touch to see bruno return
swastika nipples and all especially when
i didn't think the character would ever
make a reappearance
during the gunfight we get batman's
return and the issue ends on him making
a tough choice
saving yindle or the city the
commissioner makes it easy for him and
it's nice to see that the character
stays true to her roots
even choosing duty over death whether
she dies or not is unclear but it's a
well-deserved send-off to one of the
saga's most controversial characters
in a fittingly old-school batmobile the
caped crusader races to face the
kandorians head-on
using bats he disorientates the supermen
and causes them to fire upon each other
it speaks volumes as to how much of a
strategical man that bruce remains
and how fear and panic have always been
his greatest allies
in the turmoil the candorians disband
and the deserters are murdered
it's brilliant that whilst you cannot
overpower them using psychology
batman can still destroy them in other
ways superman races to take
down the remainders and we come to the
realization that the boy scout has in
fact been holding back
all these years merely a pacifist in the
past
he unleashes all of the power that he
had to begin with joined by
laura and the atom who had merely been
stuck in basil's shoe at an atomic level
the superhumans return
it's an outstanding face-off that allows
superman
and lara to once again become the heroes
they've had a bad rap throughout this
saga playing the villain for the
majority of it but it's great to see
that even miller understands that at
heart the man of steel and his kin
are the best of us ending on bruce and
carrie journeying off into the night and
clark teaching laura the joy of humanity
it struck me that this isn't a book
about the return of the dark knight
it's about family bruce with no heirs
had to create one by inspiring others
clark has neglected his daughter and in
some ways is responsible for her actions
instead of going out on a big bang the
book decides to instead
end sentimentally it's an inspired
choice
after all this is about passing on one's
knowledge to the next generation
that to me is what batman and superman
now represent
wise old men who wish to no longer see
those who follow make the same mistakes
i absolutely adore this ending and it
marks a fitting end for batman
i'm happy to say that batman the dark
knight returns the master race is a
great boot whilst it features slightly
lackluster issues
as a complete collection it works
brilliantly if you read this issue by
issue and were disappointed by the
seemingly never ending setup and poor
pacing
i urge you to go back and read this
collection some of it feels like fan
fiction
some of the writing is worse than the
movie scripts gerard butler gets sent
but some of it is frank miller at his
best
standing head and shoulders above the
dark knight strikes again this feels
like a fitting return to the saga
and as many moments that rival the
original boot sure
sometimes it feels a bit by the numbers
sure this is a lot broader than the
original work
sure it feels like pg-13 miller but
reigning in the creator has provided
a lot of positives i had a great time
with york and i'm greatly looking
forward to a return visit
this is a good book good enough
and that's why it gets an 8 out of 10.
i just want to say thank you for taking
the time out of your day to watch this
video
the upsurge in traffic that i've seen on
my channel has made a huge difference to
my creative process
and i've greatly enjoyed reading the all
of the dark knight returns books
in the build up to this i did actually
have the entire
video filmed but i went back and
re-edited it because
i just felt it wasn't very professional
with the
the mic i was using and the camera so i
just wanted to put
my all into it so i'd massively
appreciate it if you subscribe to my
channel
and click the thumbs up button because
it greatly helps me
even though i know this was delayed more
than the original master race book
if you like this make sure you check out
my podcast watching the watchmen that i
do with tom qui
each month we analyze the watchman
graphic novel issue by issue to see
what kind of things it deals with
thematically and it's a great journey
through the
entire graphic novel run again thank you
very much for checking this out
i'll see you next time take care peace
you